l'orgasme est une véritable conquête
[Musique]
la femme quant à moi l'homme a une
capacité multi orgasmique elle est
capable de voir plusieurs orgasmes
à condition de ne pas être distraite par
des par les parasites ou psychologiques
essentiellement qu'est ce que c'est que
les femmes fontaines site est un
phénomène d'évacuation d'une émotion
intense comme une crise de larmes comme
un cri comme quand est ce que vous avez
appris l'existence du point g est belle
je la connaissais 100 mètres de là
dessus et j'avais lu un article dans
libération qui est dit mais c'est ça je
m'étonnais que les femmes et des
sexualités si différentes et ne s'agit
plus de courir après l'orgasme il s'agit
d'être orgasmique donc toutes les
cultures ont voulu contrôler l'orgasme
alors maintenant que les femmes prennent
la parole on découvre un nouveau
continent
c'est à dire que maintenant on se rend
compte qu'il va falloir explorer ce
continent dans le point j'ai c'est pas
pour tous au même endroit pour toutes
les femmes qu'il est pratiquement à dire
[Musique]
décomplexer les femmes qui n'ont pas
d'orgasme systématiquement que janvier
une sorte de course à l'orgasme or
l'orgasme n'est pas systématique non
absolument
[Musique]